you know this guy from the church of
what's happening now you know i'm from
the longest yard joey diaz
keep it going for the flying jew one
more time
bad [__] i'm happy you guys came
out tonight thank you
for coming out testicle testaments if
people don't know it it's not a jokey
joke night tonight
it's like a storytelling night tonight
so if you don't want to [__] hear
stories you might as well go next door
and hang out with rudy and [__] which is
cool cause i'm gonna hit you i'm gonna
take you into [__] up stories tonight
because
this is the fifth chapter right so it
was like comedy and when i went to
prison and now i started commenting on
[__]
tonight's about crimes i did against
myself
like when i was out there [__] around
i did 90 percent of [__] like you robbed
people and stuff like that
but 10 percent were the crimes you did
against yourself that you could never
[__]
take care of like you can't it takes
years like i'm
just still [__] catching up on the
[__] i did to myself
you know and uh you guys are young as
you get older you'll see that you're
like what the [__] was i thinking you
know
and uh i was having a great time i
always talk about colorado like i really
really enjoy colorado when i was a kid
out of new york city
because i'd never done i never gonna ski
in new york because [__] skiing in
new york
you're in manhattan you go to new york
it's like [__] penguins and [__]
it's a sheet of ice that's it and if you
fall you die
okay when you fall when you go to
playboy mansion up there in new york
state
whatever that is up there and you fall
you just break your [__] neck
there's no bad leg or you tore your acl
it's not powder it's [__] ice
that's been packed on top of ice and
water it's not like this [__] up here
when you go to mammoth
so i went to skiing in new york one time
i didn't like it and when i went out to
colorado i fell in love with skiing and
all this [__]
and when you live in colorado it's not a
city you're surrounded by these [__]
mountains
so it's like this uh weird energy it's
like if you if you live in seattle
uh it's the deepest part in the ocean in
the united states did you guys know that
that's why they have the submarines up
in seattle because it's the deepest
[__] point they take off from there
see you learn [__] when you come to an
uncle joey testicle testament
and it's weird when you're up in seattle
if you live off energy you could feel
that it's [__] [__] up up there
it's the same in colorado those
mountains back in that [__]
and when i went to colorado i fell in
love i [__] loved it i was a 21 year
old kid 20.
[__] stealing [__] the neighbor
upstairs i was going to college
i was snorting coke smoking tremendous
weed eating mushrooms
i was [__] happy for the first time
in my life
i mean you know here i am in new york
holding the bookmaker money this guy
you know robbing drug dealers i go to
colorado i i got into college and to see
colorado mountain college i took a
course on like residential wiring and
[__]
math and history and i was burglarizing
these little i lived in
creekside right i lived in creekside
these apartments from ada like z
and my roommate was an engineer so he
devised the tool
to break into we did it with our door
but if we could break into our door we
could bring it to all the doors in the
whole [__] complex
so i just pinpointed the [__] drug
dealers i shovel snow in the daytime
and i would case the [__] buildings
out this is a great story i would case
them out
and as soon as the drug dealers would go
skiing i knew i had two or three hours
in their house
i would go and rob these drug dealers
and then shovel snow for 15 an hour
rob the houses i'm telling you i was
living like a [__] doctor you can't
wreck this [__]
i had a job case in the houses i was
gonna rob
are you [__] kid well the only thing
that could have been better is me being
security
that's the only thing that could have
been [__] better that's the only
thing i was i was making money i was
electrician
i had this neighbor that lived upstairs
she was a divorcee i was 20s
this chick was like 38 with two kids she
hit me in the face with her titties i
had never done
no but you know what i'm saying when
you're 20 you really don't get a woman
to sexually [__] molest you like that
like
you know you got to eat that [__] and
beg them for a [__] and you come too
quick
this chick was 38 she beat me and stick
fingers in my ass i loved it
i loved hanging a lot and ty i didn't
like it i love that kind of [__] you
know what i'm saying
she didn't put a dildo up my ass that's
a completely different [__] patois
20. you even take a dildo and i beat you
with a 20.
because i've never seen nothing like
that just my dildo i never seen him like
that
so for some reason and you people are
going to relate to this
because all the years have been in
situations in your life when you haven't
your life is great but for some [__]
reason
you want to go back with that loser or
you want to go back to doing drugs we
all do
it we all think that we're missing
something oh my god i'm missing
something
and at the time i was doing great in
colorado my buddies kept calling me from
jersey in new york city
like where the [__] are you we're
snorting 24 hours a [__] day we're
eating quaaludes
we're doing it all we're shooting heroin
i'm in colorado with a bunch of cowboys
listening to the [__] eagles eating
mushrooms and i'm like
you know this is cool but i'd rather be
in new york it seems like it's a lot
cooler but nah
[__] those [__] i'm gonna stay
right here in my my business but then i
go home and i do a few
bumps and i get all sentimental i'm like
i'm going to go back to new york yeah i
would those are
you know those kids i grew up with in
jersey with my family so they
when i left i didn't have a mother and a
dad i had these [__] street
savages
that were my family so i missed them so
for some reason i go
back to new york and i tell my room at
the time i'm only going back for two
weeks bro
in my heart guys i knew that was
[__] and i had a box of jewelry i
was doing all these burglaries
and hiding the jewelry in this apartment
i had up there like this condo we were
working on
and when i went to look one day i had
tons of jewelry so i had a stash of
jewelry
i brought back a block of hash i robbed
from a drug dealer that was stamped from
the emperor
[__] i'm telling you this [__] i had
some i had some souvenirs you know what
i'm saying
nobody brings you a souvenir in the old
days like you had a block of [__]
hash and it was stamped
and you had to take a piece of paper off
and it had like the gold stamp or like a
hindu like
where the [__]
blowing like a [__] snake you know
like when they got this
[Music]
and the higher the snake was up the
better the [__] hash if the snake was
by his toes [__] take it home but
but if the snake was up here [__]
doing his thing that's the [__] you
wanted to smoke you know
so i told my room and i'll be back in
two weeks and i went to new york guys
and listen to me
this is [__] crazy at the airport my
buddies pick me up
and they get in the car where they got a
[__] grandma blowing we're doing
lines
and they go have you seen this movie
scarface yet i'm like what are you
talking about scarface said like dog
it's [__] amazing
[__] going home we're going right to the
movie theater they took me to see
scarface i was like
in colorado scarface wasn't even
daughter coming out yet
he only came out in new york for like a
few weeks in miami colorado wasn't ready
for all that [__]
and i went to see scarface and it was
packed at two in the afternoon it was
sold out in the sea caucus
packed we all had to sit separate like
yeah
i had to sit in one chair my brother sat
on the other side of the [__] theater
and i watched this more i went [__]
bananas and at that time i had done some
blow
i rob some drug dealers but not like
that him cutting it with his [__]
hand and [__]
i'm in i'm in that's it i'm in i want to
do that [__]
[__] going back i don't want to ski i
want to cut the [__] blow with my
hand